you uh are busier now in retirement than
you've ever been
and i really admire you for this you are
everywhere
you're constantly working you've got so
much going on
um you're just you're an incredibly busy
guy what are you
where are you right now first of all
somewhere in the world okay you're not
telling me you don't trust me
you don't know i don't trust who
watching you okay all right so you're
somewhere in the world
i'm somewhere in the world right now
okay
i saw this picture of you this is a very
cool thing you do
um you gave out turkeys look at this
i keep this picture with me at all times
because it inspires me
you gave out turkeys in hawaii and
california with your
fam first family foundation that is
really
admirable that you do that um
and and really amazing and you're also
now
you're trying to get coding classes
you're trying to get kids
who are in need some coding classes tell
us about that
well they actually already doing it um
uh
uh
shout out to shopify but uh we put
together this beast mode of business
where we brought in maybe 20 kids from
the inner city who had
no idea about coding so we gave him an
uh we know provided them with uh laptops
and uh
the kids gave them the business plans
and they turned their business plans
into online businesses uh you know for
them to be able to create and generate
money
right and i would say at least maybe
five other kids actually still have
sustainable businesses
that uh that they had uh made
but i mean throughout our foundation uh
we've been doing
uh coding for um i'll say about the last
maybe three to four years that's amazing
see the coding is just one thing
i mean we got architect uh classes where
these kids build models of
you know because we have a youth center
now so the youth center they build
models of what they want the youth
center to look like once we get our
coins right
and i mean you know just to put these
type of
like architect i know when i was a
youngster i hear architect i'm like
out of here i don't know that he had
code and like code and what
uh cheat code on a video game like
nah but they they they
they dive into this and then they show
me something that
like the passion that they that they
have behind it i think it's more so just
you know people in position being able
to show them that it's actually out
there and able for them to do
yeah because i mean every time yeah and
also that it's
possible it's pos and i think sometimes
people think
if they come from a background where
they don't have access to computers they
don't have access they think
i could never do that but when and then
they create a mental block
and if someone at any early age says
here it is and yes you can do this
there's no mental block
you're right that see man what i learned
uh
what i learned is like this these kids
imaginations
like if if you don't if you don't block
them see mine was blocked they told me
it was either going to be
sports penitentiary or or the casket
and then i mean you know i don't lost so
many people starting at the
early age of seven like uh you know i
might try to get this sports thing to
try that you feel me and that was
that was that was where my mind had went
but everything else was
it was shut out for me because i never
had no inspiration to go be nothing
besides
an athlete but now i see that you know
we get hey you could go be an engineer
like what's the engineer or you could go
be the second ad
on a on on on a movie set like what's
the second a.d
and then i just learned what's a gaffer
and you know all kind of
that i mean now i'm going to teach my
kids that and it's just like man
the the more you allow them to show you
that uh what they're labeled as
is not the truth yeah you'll be you'll
be surprised every time
yeah when you were when you were a kid
did people
try to tell you because you've shown
outside of sports
that you're this great force you're an
entrepreneur
you're you're you're just you know uh
you're so smart about creating these
different foundations you're making such
great decisions
did you know you were capable of all
that when you were a kid or did people
convince you that you weren't able to do
that kind of thing
nah man big dog i'm gonna tell y'all
who all the way from elementary school
uh you know all the way through cal i've
been in special resource programs
and i mean it wasn't until about high
school when i when i finally got it like
man that
i'm gonna go ask for help right and once
i did that once i
once i put all that other you stupid you
got
80d you got adhd you got all this
but man get it all right cool hey can
you help me
and once i once i figured out that can
you help me
then everything else was just yeah i
mean small selling to keep it solid with
you
right and now it's to the point where i
just got a uh
honorary degree from uh from princeton
so i mean
you feel me they you know what i mean
from the town that could say i got a
degree from president after being called
stupid and you ain't gonna be you're
gonna be dead or in jail
blah blah blah blah blah man boss me
that's great that is fantastic that is i
mean that makes me
that makes that's the nicest thing i've
heard in in a dark time that is one of
the greatest things i've heard
god bless you for that that is amazing